anything that's funny is because it's
real which is what i thought was true in
the fighter or some of my favorite films
are are funny because they're they're
dramas but they're funny because
people are very committed to who they
are emotionally they're authentic and it
also means the community bradley is from
philadelphia right near where we shot
um it felt very
uh
familiar and real to us the world that
we created you know the primary source
is the novel and then david wrote an
amazing screenplay but he also is
writing on the day while we're shooting
within the take he'll he'll he'll give
us lines in in the moment um and he is
also open for exploration for
improvisation as well
um and then we'll we'll go back and and
rewrite right before if the scene's not
working and go right back into it it's a
very uh malleable product it's a very
organic process as it's happening
we modulated pat solitano on the first
couple of days to sort of find the sweet
spot of where he lives because we you
know and that's something that wasn't
you know you're not going into it with
an iron fist you're finding it and
you're and you're doing that by making
everything as he said real
one facet of this and it isn't always
that way but a lot of the times how
david likes to work
is to
allow the actors to do the whole scene
from beginning to end
um without having to stop and do
different pieces of coverage so a lot of
times he's on steadicam and
um
what i think we realized very quickly um
and not to speak for battling the gang
but it's it's you know it's heaven for
the actors because they really get to
feel like they're in the moment they're
in the scene they're at the place
they're having the real experience from
beginning to end they don't have to stop
and start over and over again they don't
have to wait for an hour after they've
done the master to do their close-up
it's all just happening real time and
the coverage is all within he'll shoot
this way he'll shoot that way you lit
360 most of those sets so that
the fluidity of the camera work was
incredible
but it made it there was a real process
of discovery and i look at the film now
and
the thing i learned from it which is
fantastic is what you don't need and and
the the reductive process of what we
took out
and we don't need it and none of it
should come back danny elfman who did
the score who came in and and um
who obviously is such a brilliant
composer but what was so brilliant about
what he did was is that he came in
he really loved the movie and responded
to it and obviously like you said
there's so much great music source music
that's in the movie that that david's
populated with and he really came in and
found a way where at times you don't
know where the source ends and this and
the score begins because he kind of
comes you know it's really just guitar
and drums and
you know piano and bass it's a very it's
very spare the way he did it but it's so
powerful and emotional and it's it was
it was such a great collaboration i feel
because he just found a way to
musically integrate himself into what
was already there in the film when david
called and said you know the roles
available and i want you to do it i
thought you know i'm just this is kind
of a stretch i'm not really i don't
really have any similarities to pat
meanwhile i'm from philly and i'm
italian irish like pat i love the eagles
i mean i can't find thing it's much
harder to find things that i'm not like
the character than like but i think i
was so terrified uh because i would have
because knowing it the way he works
by the movies that he's made um the way
i assume he worked everybody seems like
they're not acting to me and i thought
wow this guy
has to go through a lot of um
that's sort of an emo emotional
rollercoaster how am i gonna be able to
do this on film and then
and even like something like how am i
going to cry really on film that's
frightening and uh
and so i was scared to do it yeah but
then of course excited because the whole
reason why i ever wanted to become an
actor would be to work with people like
this um and a cast like this oh my gosh
this cast is just incredible besides
robert de niro is incredible but
jennifer lawrence is just uh
you know
sydney pollock and anthony mangella uh
gave me the book five years ago and i
thought we were going to make the
picture actually before the fighter
and sydney said matthew quick has a
really great voice
that captures this community and most
importantly it was a personal thing
otherwise i never would have
i think
looked at it so so closely but you know
um
i've had personal experiences with this
my son
is the young man who rings the doorbell
in the picture
and he's you know he has had
many of these challenges so when sydney
pollock said to me i'm not sure how
you're going to get the tone of this
right because it's very tricky
i said i think i think i know from the
inside you know because i know the the
sad parts and the funny parts as long as
we just do it real i i love i just love
storytelling through the cinema through
cinema i i love it i'm obsessed by it
and um
so to be you know for this man to say
hold my hand and we're going to walk
down this road together
you know i'm going to take full
advantage of it and uh so i just you
know was a student of his through this
whole process much more than just being
the actor of pat solitano